we have to make sure that we don't just
fix the parts that are broken we also
have to make sure we don't break the
parts that are actually working very
well hi I'm Ted bellacor with reason TV
today i'll be speaking with economist
Glenn Whitman dr. Whitman is co-author
along with Raymond rod of the new Cato
Institute policy analysis bending the
productivity curve why America leads the
world in medical innovation let's get
right into the key points of your of
your study what if you had to boil it
down to a few of them what what were
they everybody realizes that the
American system of health care is very
far from ideal and the real question is
not whether we're going to reform it but
how but if we're going to do that we
have to make sure that we don't just fix
the parts that are broken we also have
to make sure we don't break the parts
that are actually working very well and
it turns out that one of the areas that
America is really great at is medical
innovation in fact we lead the world in
medical innovation whether it's basic
medical research or Diagnostics or
therapeutics it turns out the United
States leads the world it's ahead of any
other country and often greater than all
other countries combined and I think
what one thing there were many things
interesting about your study it's not
just we're a big country with a lot of
people you compared the u.s. against the
EU plus Switzerland in a lot of cases
the EU plus Switzerland is has a lot
more people compared to the u.s. that's
right Europe actually has a population a
good bit higher the United States the
European Union countries plus
Switzerland to have a combined
population about fifty percent higher
than the United States and yet the level
of innovation in the European Union in
Switzerland is actually a good bit lower
than that at the United States and you
also point to a lot of some common
problems with international health care
comparisons a lot of them leave out this
this crucial factor of innovation when
people do international comparisons of
healthcare they often look just at life
expectancy or just an infant mortality
or some other measure of the health of
the population and of course you want to
look at those things but you also have
to be looking at the level of innovation
produced in different
countries and the problem is is that the
innovation that the United States
produces we bear the cost for that and
that shows up in our cost statistics and
it's one of the reasons that we end up
spending more than other countries and
yet the benefits of our innovation don't
just show up in our healthcare
statistics it will show up in every
country healthcare statistics or at
least those of the countries that
actually use the innovations that we
create which is most of them especially
the developed countries you looked at a
variety of different ways you know you
can how do you slice innovation you can
slice in a bunch of different ways one
is for instance Nobel Prize winners
correct it turns out that the United
States has had more Nobel Prize winners
in the area of medicine and physiology
then all other countries combined and
this is if you measure it by the
individuals who have received it or the
number of years in the last 40 years or
so that an American has been among the
recipients and another thing you guys
did was look at not just all innovations
but according to a wide survey of
doctors what they regard as the most
important innovations and what did you
find it at regard if you look at the
list of innovations meaning both
treatments and drugs are masuda goals
and diagnostics that doctors tend to
agree are the most important innovations
of the last 30 to 40 years it turns out
that many of those innovations came for
the United States in fact more from the
United States then came from the
European Union and Switzerland combined
what are one or two examples of those
we're talking about ace inhibitors for
blood pressure treatment we're talking
about selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors which are a treatment for
depression we're talking about treatment
for cataracts all of these are areas
where the United States has made
important contributions that have
benefited the entire world now often
when people point out how innovative
America is compared to other nations
common rejoinder is well you know that's
because the NIH government funding how
do you respond to that that is part of
the picture but it's also the case that
there is a massive amount
private investment that's taking place
in the United States that again would
make the amount it contributed by Europe
looks small and it's also at different
kinds of innovations when you're talking
about what the government funds versus
what pharmaceutical companies and such
actually develop correct so when you're
talking about government funding usually
what you're talking about is the funding
for basic scientific research so it
might be that NIH funding is helpful for
understanding why the US has a lead in
Nobel Prize winners but when it comes to
understanding why the United States
leads the world when it comes to
diagnostics and therapeutics essentially
where the medical knowledge hits the
road and actually helps people's lives
gives us better treatments and
diagnostics in that case you're not
talking primarily about the government
funding for the NIH what you're talking
about is individual practitioners you're
talking about pharmaceutical companies
you're talking about medical device
companies which are actually inventing
the means by which to do these
treatments so you mentioned the US is
doing plenty of things wrong when it
comes to to health care but in this area
of innovation we're doing a lot of
things right what are we doing right
well oddly enough it seems paradoxical
but some of the things that were
criticized for and perhaps rightly so
are also things that are part of our
advantage when it comes to innovation if
you think about what kind of incentives
the innovators actually need among other
things they need monetary incentives
they need to know that they're going to
get a higher return they're going to get
it sooner and they're going to get it
for a longer period of time well as it
turns out in the United States we use a
great deal of these innovations we tend
to use them faster and we tend to
diffuse their use a lot more quickly as
well the result of that is often that we
end up paying more we both use the
treatments more often and we pay more
for them and this is often regard as a
defect of the u.s. system and perhaps it
is but we have to realize it's not just
bad there's also an upside which is that
it adds to the incentive that innovators
have to create great products that we're
going to be able to use to improve our
lives and then if the u.s. is the model
of how to do it right at least in terms
of innovation you point you and your
co-author point to the UK
in the Nordic nations as places where
innovation is not going so well what are
they doing wrong well among other things
they have centrally organized healthcare
systems that give a great deal of buyer
power bargaining power to the government
to decide what kinds of new treatments
are going to be used how quickly and
what price is going to be paid for them
and basically it's using the power of
government to cram down the expenditures
that are made on health care but at the
same time what they're also doing is
cramming down the amount of innovation
that's going to take place as well when
you have restrictions on the rate of
diffusion of new technologies and how
quickly people are going to be able to
use a technology when it comes available
obviously that's going to reduce the
return that an innovator is going to get
for creating that innovation in the
first place but in some sense they can
have their cake and eat it too they may
not give innovations as quickly or as
much of them as we get but and this is
another point you mentioned that to a
large extent the rest of the world is
free riding off the US can you explain
that Americans end up spending a lot
more on the results of innovation in the
medical field what we're doing is we're
creating a much greater incentive for
these innovators to create their
products in the first place meanwhile
the rest of the world is able to use
those products once they've already been
created and they're able to do so at a
relatively low price what that means is
essentially the United States is
subsidizing the rest of the world so a
lot of the drug manufacturers know that
they'll still have the massive US market
where they can make a bunch of money so
who cares if they're price controls and
Canada is that more or less it exactly
so if you take a pharmaceutical company
what is the real incentive that gets
them to create the product in the first
place is the fact I know they're going
to have a large market in the United
States so then the question becomes what
happens if the u.s. moves more in their
direction because I hear of surveys from
the UK for instance where people say
generally speaking you know we like our
health care then they hear about the
different sorts of procedures drugs
treatments that are available in the US
suddenly they don't like their health
care quite as much if we end up adopting
a system that is more like that which
they have in Canada
and in Western Europe it may seem like
things are going just fine except for
the fact that there are still births in
the area of innovation innovations we
could have had treatments that we could
have had drugs that we could have had
but we'll never see them and will never
realize that we could have been living
longer happier lives